WHAT WE SHOULD ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
TO DO, ESPECIALLY THOSE ALONE AN
ANXIOUS RIGHT NOW.
KEVIN, THANK YOU.
>> YOU BET.
>> Shannon: THERE IS
BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT AMONG
SENATORS AND AT ONE POINT CHINA
TO IMMEDIATELY CLOSE THOSE WET
MARKETS.
LET’S BRING IN THE SENATOR
MIKE LEE TO TALK ABOUT THAT,
GOOD TO HAVE YOU BACK WITH US.
>> THANK YOU, IT IS GOOD TO BE
WITH YOU.
>> Shannon: OKAY, LET’S START
WITH CHINA.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE SOME NATIONAL
INTEREST, TALKING ABOUT THE FACT
AMERICA AND CHINA STILL HAVE TO
GET ALONG WHEN THIS IS OVER.
THE CRISIS WILL EVENTUALLY PASS,
BUT THERE WILL BE OTHERS AND
THEY TOO WILL REQUIRE BEIJING
WITH STRATEGIC COMPETITION TO
REQUIREMENTS.
THE PANDEMIC WITH A PARROT UPON
THE SHARPEST POSSIBLE RELIEF.
SENATOR, WILL THEY DO IT?
SHOULD WE DO IT?
>> LOOK MY THINK NO MATTER WHAT,
THERE IS GOING TO BE DIRE
CONSEQUENCES FOR CHINA.
THIS IS A PLACE THAT FOSTER THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE VIRUS TO
BEGIN WITH AND FIELDED THE
SEVERITY.
AND REGARDLESS OF ANY ACTION THE
GOVERNMENT TAKES, CONSUMERS WILL
TAKE ACTION.
I EXPECT THE GOVERNMENT WILL
TAKE ACTION AS WELL.
WE WILL SEE TRADE RESTRICTIVE
FOR A TIME.
CHINA IS GOING TO BE A NET LOSER
AND THAT.
>> Shannon: OKAY, LET’S TALK
ABOUT THE FACT OVER ON THE THE H
TODAY, WITHOUT THIS AND IT MIGHT
TAKE ACTION.
IT DIDN’T GET DONE.
THE SECRETARY OF TREASURY MINUTE
AND HAS BEEN TALKING WITH
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS AND MAJORI
MITCH McCONNELL TALKED ABOUT
THE FACT THEY WERE TRYING TO
GET SOMETHING DOWN BY A VOICE OF
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO MOVE THIS
FUNDING ALONG TO REPLENISH SMALL
BUSINESS LOANS.
IT DIDN’T HAPPEN BECAUSE
DEMOCRATS CAME FORWARD WITH
THEIR OWN LIST WHAT THEY WANTED
TO ADD TO THAT.
HERE IS WHAT THE HELL SPEAKER
HAD TO SAY TODAY.
>> YOU MAY HAVE SEEN THIS
MORNING THAT THIS STUNT WAS
PERFORMED BY THE SENATE LEADER
KNOWING THAT IT WOULD FAIL AND
MANY PEOPLE DON’T HAVE BANKING
RELATIONSHIPS WERE GOING TO BE
LAST IN LINE.
AND THAT IS WHY THEY ASKED FOR
MORE MONEY, WE SAID, LET’S HOPE
EVERYBODY HERE, HELP THE BANKS
DO WHAT THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO DO.
THIS BE WHEN SHE’S NOT THE ONLY
ONE CALLING OUT LEADER
McCONNELL, THE TOP DEMOCRAT IN
THE SENATE CHUCK SCHUMER SAID
THIS "SENATOR MITCH McCONNELL
BLOCKED A BILL THAT PROVIDES
MONEY FOR SMALL BUSINESSES,
HOSPITAL, TESTING AND MORE
INSTEAD OF WORKING WITH THE
HOUSE AND DEMOCRAT PEOPLE.
THEY USE THAT SAME WORD STUNT.
SENATOR, WHAT HAPPENED ON THE
POOR TODAY?
>> FIRST OF ALL, IT IS VERY
CLEAR THAT THERE IS DEMOCRATIC
COLLUSION WITH THE MESSAGE
SHOULD BE.
WHAT HAPPENED ON THE SENATE
FLOOR WAS DISGRACEFUL.
THE FACT THAT DEMOCRATS CAME
FORWARD AND REFUSED TO LEND
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR A PROGRAM
THAT JUST DAYS AGO, SHANNON,
THEY SUPPORTED WHOLEHEARTEDLY.
THEY REFUSED TO SUPPORT IT TODAY
KNOWING MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
NEED THIS ASSISTANCE SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO SCORE
ADDITIONAL POINTS.
THEY WANTED TO BUILD GOVERNMENT
AND THE WAY THEY DEEM FIT.
THIS ISN’T RIGHT, AND THEY KNOW
IT.
>> Shannon: WELL, THERE ARE
WORRIES ACROSS THE AISLE ABOUT
THE PRICE TAGS THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT NOW GETTING INTO
$5 TRILLION, $6 TRILLION IN
RELIEF IN SOME CASES PEER OF THE
PRESENT COMMITTEE RESPONSIBLE
WITH FEDERAL BUDGET SAID THIS
"IT FEELS LIKE THE POLITICIANS
ARE TRYING TO USE THIS NATIONAL
EMERGENCY TO FAVORITE POLICIES
WHILE AVOID PAYING FOR THEM."
WE AGREED THIS IS A DIRE MOMENT
IN THE NATION’S ECONOMY, BUT HOW
DO WE GET A HANDLE ON WHAT WE
ARE DOING OUT OF TAXPAYERS
DOLLARS AND WHAT WE HANDLE WITH
THE DEFICIT BEING GENERATED BY
THE RELIEF PACKAGE IS THAT SO
MANY PEOPLE ARE COUNTING ON
RIGHT NOW?
>> LOOK, SHANNON, THERE IS NO
QUESTION WE HAVE A DEBT AND
DEFICIT PROBLEM.
WE HAVE TO WORK OUR WAY OUT OF
THE SITUATION WE FIND OURSELVES
IN WITH A GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS SOLUTION TO
THIS WAS TO ADD MORE TO THE
PRICE TAG AND TO CAUSES MONEY TO
GO EVEN LESS FAR.
THAT WAS WRONG.
>> Shannon: OKAY, I WANT TO
ASK YOU TOO BECAUSE YOU WERE
TRACKING HOSPITAL BEDS.
THEY ARE VERY VALUABLE RIGHT
NOW.
EVERYBODY KEEPING AN EYE TO MAKE
SURE THESE ARE AVAILABLE IN
COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE ARE
SPIKES, BUT THERE IS A TRADE
DISPUTE OR SOMETHING GOING ON
REGARDING ACTUAL MATTRESSES USED
FOR HOSPITAL BEDS.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> THERE IS INDEED, THERE IS A
COMPANY THAT MAKES GOOD
MATTRESSES, BUT THEY’VE DONE A
VERY BAD THING HERE.
THEY FILED A PETITION WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL TRADE COMMISSION.
THE NET EFFECT OF WHICH IS TO
SHUT DOWN THE IMPORTATION OF
MATTRESSES AT A TIME WHEN WE
HAVE 50,000 TO 70,000 MATTRESSES
NEEDED IN HOSPITAL ROOMS RIGHT
NOW.
THE DOMESTIC MANUFACTURERS LED
BY THEM AND NOT MANUFACTURE
BEING CLOSE TO THAT IN THE NEXT
FIVE MONTHS.
SO LOOK, THEY MADE A MISTAKE AND
THEY NEED TO ADMIT THEY ARE
WRONG.
AND THEY NEED ONE HERE.
THEY MADE A BIG MISTAKE.
I THINK IT IS A MISTAKE FOR THEM
TO BE UTILIZING THE ITC PROCESS
TO SHUT OUT COMPETITION IN A WAY
THAT WILL HARM THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE DURING THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC, LIMITING THEIR ACCESS
TO HOSPITAL BEDS, WHICH ARE
EIGHT ESSENTIAL MEDICAL DEVICE
NEEDED FOR COVID-19 TREATMENT.
>> Shannon: THERE ARE SO MANY
THINGS THAT COME ALONG WITH THIS
PANDEMIC THAT WE COULD NOT HAVE
FORESEEN SIX TO EIGHT WEEKS AGO.
IT GETS COMPLICATED.
SENATOR, WE ARE GLAD YOU’RE
LOOKING WELL AFTER YOUR OWN
PERSONAL QUARANTINE.